a recent study showed that if you put 20
liters in a room 20 liters in a room
only one out of the 20 is a strategic
thinker
meaning they think about strategies on
how to out maneuver their opponents
one in 20 i know we've heard buffett say
things like
there's three qualities we hire for
intelligence
you know initiative and integrity and if
you don't have the last one the first
two don't matter
i know we hear that but when it comes
down to business
at the end of the day the person that's
able to out maneuver their peers say
they all work hard say they're all
reading books say they're all improving
but one guy keeps becoming more and more
and more strategic
long term i'm just going to break it
break it to you you're not going to be
able to beat that guy
even if you work the same amount of
hours he or she works you'll eventually
have to improve
your strategy game so today we're going
to talk about what you can do to improve
your strategy game
[Music]
so by the way today whatever i talk
about i'm going to give you a pdf so i
hang titled
let me get right into it when it comes
down to strategy most people think oh
he's a strategic thinker
he's a strategist what is it really
about
when you talk about strategy and i'll
leave an article below that you should
read about this topic
here's how it works out strategy comes
down to three different ways of thinking
there is the short-term strategist the
midterm strategist
the long-term strategist you may be
watching this and you don't even know it
you're a better short-term strategist
you may be watching this and you don't
even know it you're a better midterm and
some of you are good long-term now
here's the challenge
some people are great with long-term
strategies but they suck in short-term
and mid-term
you can't compete with somebody that's
good at all three and
some people are good at term strategies
but they're not good at midterm and long
term so what is the difference between
short term midterm and long term let me
kind of unpack so that makes sense to
you
short term thinkers are problem solvers
meaning something happens here's what i
think we need to do immediate decisions
wait we move on
midterm thinkers they think like a
strategist
long-term thinkers they're planning
their next
strategy now timeline wise the
short-term thinker could be a second
problem solver
somebody comes up hey here's what you're
saying what should we do i think we
should do this okay great let's move on
that was seven seconds right
hey this what's going on what should we
be doing with this well let me have we
asked this person
what about this and give me the data
what's the report look like what did
they say what are they saying the email
45 minutes later decisions been made but
that's a second to an hour strategist
short-term thinker immediate immediate
immediate
you're a problem solver the midterm one
is day to day
so you know tomorrow we have a board
meeting and the guy's going to be asking
this question
and i really have no answer from what
are we going to say when we say our
expenses are high in this one year we
spent seven million dollars
and last year same time we only spent
2.8 million what do we say
well let's go back and look what we
unpacked the 7 million for me we did
this and why do we spend the money over
here
is it fair to say that the 7 million we
spend it's going to help us out next to
yes it is
boom okay can you get this research
within 24 hours you have the info next
day at the board meeting 24 hours
here's why we have 7 million here
instead of 2.7 million and you actually
bring it up with all the data and they
say
okay we're not happy about it but it
makes sense
timeline on the long term is planning
for next month what are we going to be
doing next month
what is the plans next quarter what's
the plans in q4
what's the plan 2021 2022 2023
or what's the plan the next five-year
vision 10-year vision 20-year vision
there are many people who are very good
here but they're not good here again so
next one
short-term strategist is a street
fighter you go into a street fight it
lasts less than a minute
boom boom you leave it's done fight's
over with right that's short term
one small little brawl a bar fighter
brawl second one is a battle
this is this is something that's going
to be going on it's a battle it's a lot
of people involved you
it's going on maybe it lasts a little
longer you're trying to win this battle
the
last one is a war so the war knows how
to look at everything because war
typically lasts a long time
so they have to look at that street
fight was won by this gang that little
battle we lost but what did we learn
from this battle that left us clues
and the data to know that next time
we're going to flank from this angle and
we're going to send to people and
we got to create an alliance there
that's a different level of thinking
that very few people spend a lot of time
most people are here believe it or not
most people are not here next short term
you're putting out fires you're a
firefighter
middle one you're preventing fire the
last one is you're building and deciding
where you're going to put your fire
stations
so oh my gosh put out the fire oh we got
another fire let me put that on oh
another five we're going to put
this one we got to make sure we have 19
you know hoses everywhere
this one is no no we need one fire
station and that zip code one fire
station and this zip code one fire
station this school we need to teach
courses we need to make videos we need
to make education we need to go to
schools
different way of thinking again band-aid
short-term thinking surgery midterm
long-term lifestyle if you stop eating
sugar if you drink more water if you
exercise
you're going to be able to avoid the
band-aid or the surgery because you're
more prepared and it's a long-term
lifestyle
are you kind of getting the idea of the
difference between these thinkers right
this is just to kind of give you an idea
you got to ask yourself
and even comment below are you a
short-term strategist a midterm
strategist or a long-term in which one
of these areas can you improve and
comment below
so now let's set this aside and let's
talk about what a real strategist thinks
about
number one everything about a strategist
is about anticipation remember this guy
anticipates what could happen so he
prevents a band-aid and a surgery
this guy's not anticipation like oh
let's just go let's just go let's just
go
anticipation is number one and how do
you anticipate
by gathering as much intel and data as
you can for example
what kind of intel can you get intel on
the industry from the industry expert
intel from somebody that used to be with
a former competitor company and you
recruit them
until from an article you get intel from
somebody that works for regulator intel
from
this is intel that you're gathering then
intel from the inside store inside
intel from hey my uh office that we sell
our phones through at this radio shack
the sales leader there does
xyz and he has this issue and three
employees told us that at work he's
always smoking weed and the guys haven't
hit their numbers for the last
that is intel i need you need that intel
to anticipate a problem you could face
with that chop so you got to prevent it
before it happens right intel then it's
best case
worst case strategies what's the worst
case that can happen if we do this here
oh that's pretty bad what's the best
case okay great
let's see what we can do to make worst
case better number two
non-emotional critical thinking i put
ego out of the co it's very hard to do
for a lot of people because
i've been in a lot of rooms where one of
my own guys that work for me maybe an
executive or sales leader
absolutely offended me and insulted me
in the
worst possible way in a room i'm talking
about
the worst way which is semi-embarrassing
right
and in that moment for me i can sit
there and just
trash this guy because i knew everything
about him and just
ruined his reputation but i didn't
nothing was said
i just stood there and i'm like okay
let's take a quick break
and we walked off boom we come back and
bring the meeting together set the tone
we start
in that moment i know what i can do but
that's based on ego
if i go there if i would have done that
during that time with my ego
i would have potentially lost three
accounts if i would have lost those
three accounts to value the company for
that time so i had to be patient to know
that eventually
everyone's going to know who the leader
in this room is and everyone's going to
figure out what the right decisions
being made
but if the ego was in the way that would
have never happened so let's talk about
this constantly challenging your own
views
constantly are we doing the right thing
here this is how we've done this has it
worked did it work is our philosophy the
right approach
because to have the right philosophy
takes years sometimes people don't have
the right philosophy
that could take 5 10 15 years to get 100
confident about your philosophy that you
have like coaches
you know it takes a while for coaches to
get their philosophy down your approach
your leadership way of thinking meaning
not you then you have to kind of start
thinking and saying well
my guy here the way he thinks i just
think he keeps getting in his own way
what can i do to encourage this guy
i understand how he's wired i understand
how she's what you're thinking about all
this stuff in a critical thinking way
being upfront with issues with your
leaders for example for
the first two three years when i started
my own financial form i was not
comfortable talking about real issues
i had some data that was scary data the
first two years and it almost put us out
of business i realized as a 32 year old
look if you're gonna go like this and
you're worried about only giving
positive data you're going to put
yourself out of business so what did i
do
all right we're going to have a call i
set up a call i terminated three people
i fired my number one producer at the
time hurt me a lot
but i made the decision and we talked
about exactly what things could put us
out of business
and everybody on the call was like whoa
that was a different kind of call
and the reaction i thought i was going
to get from everybody was a complete
opposite reaction people said thank you
so much for being transparent this was
great this is exactly what we needed
and there was a couple people that
weren't happy about me because i
i talked about exactly what things they
were doing that was hurting the company
and eventually some of them changed some
of them left but the company got bigger
so you cannot be afraid
of having critical thinking type of
conversations then you got to challenge
hypocrisy which exists we get it every
single week here
with some people that have hypocrisy in
the field that i have to be able to
manage and work with
you have to challenge manipulation which
happens in every organization and every
war in every battle and every company
in every organization there's gonna be
manipulation
and bias by executives and different
organizations meaning
somebody may want to make a decision
that they have a certain bias because it
benefits them and their department and
their
you know pocket and bottom line more
than it does yours and you you cannot be
naive to know why that person's thinking
the way they do you have to know that
because you're being
a critical thinker and setting aside
what ego non-emotional critical thinkers
so that's number two number three
interpret motive now you're not always
going to get motive because
you don't get paid to go out there and
you know you didn't go to college or
school and you have a lie detective test
where you know everybody's motive what
they're doing but you are a
poker player and you're trying to read
some people's tales to see what people's
motives are
some of them are in your organization
some of them are clients some of them
are enemies so when you break down
motive
looking at all options based on data
with the best possible approach
taken and then relevant and irrelevant
data so if i'm looking at motive and i'm
trying to
interpret motive why are they doing what
they're doing then i look at the data
and i said this makes sense
the reason why they're pushing this
agenda is because the other number
that's really the one that they need to
work on
would embarrass them and it's hurting
them so their argument is to use the
data
that shows that they're doing something
right versus the argument so i totally
get their
motive why they're doing what they're
doing i got it i see their data it's not
growing their organization you can look
at the number you can look at the
business
it's flat line income's but i get the
motive behind it i understand it's a
little embarrassing when your business
doesn't do well
and you have certain motives but you
have to be able to interpret
everybody's motive number four
you gotta have the guts to decide and
what i mean by guts to decide is
yes you need to build trust with the
team but at the same time you cannot be
afraid of not making a big decision just
because one team member doesn't trust
you
just because one team member gives you a
hard time just because one team member
is
never going to be on your side you can't
allow that to get you to say well we
have to make sure we have 100
consensus it's never going to be the
case so you being able to take a stand
and make a decision a few years ago i
got up and
i was trying to please everybody and the
company you know i'm talking
well i have to make sure i please this
guy and that guy i left i came back
and i said we're solving for one of two
things
either this company is going to become
the company that i envisioned for it to
be
where we're going to have a half a
million licensed agents and it's going
to compete with everybody in the market
you place northwestern mutual everybody
in the marketplace we're going to
compete with
or we're going to be out of business but
i'm not solving for the middle
i'm solving for this and if i push too
hard for this we'll be here
i'm totally good with that it's almost
like i don't want to stand up fighting
and
losing and telling the story to say i
lost the fight but i lost the standing i
would much rather take the ali approach
who was knocked out multiple times but
he fought you
knowing he's going to give his best to
fight you and if you knock them out
guess what
i salute you respect to you for knocking
my ass out
but i'm going to fight you if we're
going to go at it right so that idea
once i took a stand
and i was i went away from being afraid
of what everybody was thinking and i
took a stand i had the gust to make a
decision
everything changed as a strategist
number five align
understanding every party's involved
agenda so
the idea is to try to get as many people
aligned on the same page as possible
it's very very hard to do
it's hard to do in a family it's hard to
do in a marriage all the time
it's hard to do in a sports team it's
it's the hardest thing you'll ever do
right
you hear a lot of experts you read about
they say the toughest thing to ever do
in an organization
is to get people to work together as a
team it's the hardest thing to do
because
the reason why it's hard to work as a
team is why credit he wants credit
she wants credit that guy wants credit
this guy was because of me it's because
of that guys because it is
so it's hard to create an environment
that's very competitive and people are
working their assets up because they
want to get the credit
and you still want us to be aligned a
little bit tough to do it but it's
doable
it's what great organization like the
bulls did it's what great organizations
and companies have done is what great
military
has done and it's doable once you get
there and you have everybody on the same
page
and you implement the strategy you
presented people buying and they execute
it's game over from there especially if
you have the right execution in place
number six learn challenge constant
improvement with leadership team why do
i put
challenge constant improvement
leadership team here's why
you know who typically is very open to
learning and improving
newer people you know it's typically
very hungry we don't want to prove a
point to you
people that are coming up you know where
the hardest people to challenge to
constantly think and learn the people
that have been off on the longest
you know who i have the hardest time
getting to read books those guys like
well you know what i've read
it's kind of like this but yeah i'll
skim through it no no read the damn book
you've been stuck for five years because
you don't read books
read the book ah it's okay i've read it
i read it came through yeah i read it
and you know they haven't read the book
right
because they keep declining because
they're not doing this now
i do have on the other hand i just
promoted somebody chief distribution
officer the company matt sappolo
phenomenal guy that i promoted
and this is a guy we're very happy by
the last four or five years we paid him
5.5 million
they're on track to make two million
this year right he gets the promotion
why does he get the promotion
because till today he and his wife
sheena are
constantly taking my challenges of them
improving
and they constantly improve and they
constantly improve and it can't improve
while most stop so you got to constantly
challenge your leaders at the top to
improve because if they do people follow
suit and they improve as well
and last but not least in this section
of learning is debrief both
successes and losses most people only
debrief a
loss most people don't debrief a success
meaning oh we won why do we win tell me
why we won
why do we win we won because of what
instead it's like oh it's awesome
we want oh why do we win we have to take
the time out right now figure out why we
won
well we won because of dot dot dot okay
good why do we lose that's also not easy
to do
you got to do that when you take this
approach you keep constantly getting
better
and better and better with your
strategies now a couple other things on
here and i'll wrap up
strategies there's conventional thinking
of strategy oh how do they do it we're
going to do that how does she do it
we're going to do that
then there's unconventional thinking
which you become creative they ask
napoleon
which general did you study in the
history books and you mimicked he says
nobody i studied everybody but i come up
with my own strategies because that's
the shock
factor that's how you shock everybody in
the marketplace not doing everybody
what everybody else said you shock them
a little bit with slightly different
strategies that you have in place
inside the box strategies outside the
box strategies
only logical thinking is logic emotion
and four-dimensional thinking what's
four-dimensional thinking
based on the data we are we ought to be
doing these three things
but emotionally we're not in a good
place with her we're in a very good
place with them
they would be very happy with us they
would not be happy with this okay
emotionally
four-dimensional if we did this the
effects of this would go here that would
go here this would upset this
we're okay with that let's go ahead and
do it but if we did this and we and it
upset this person that person's a
partner it's a very important part
like sono ceo comes out and says we
think
amazon is selling our prod products
cheaper than it's really
what we sell it to them what do you mean
we sell our products to amazon say for
amazon is selling them now for 380.
that's breaking the law
and bazel says yes we do sell the
products cheaper than we buy them but
because it's on a promotion
and then the ceo says that is illegal
you shouldn't be able to do something
like this well first of all ceo
be very careful who you're saying that
to number one you produce your products
in china
so you are the one that's producing your
products in china to save money you just
raise your prices 50
in january because you not want to build
it in america
and imagine if bezos turns around and
says sorry sonos
you are so upset with us moving forward
you can no longer sell sonos on amazon
because
it's upsetting you so much did you see
the four dimensional thinking
that you're not thinking about you're
calling out amazon
amazon's selling your products what are
you talking about here
maybe not the best strategy the ceo of
sonos is taking maybe not the best
strategy
especially since there's nobody bigger
than amazon you want to be able to be on
amazon with the product that chef
and i'm a sonos guy god knows how many
sonos have i got sonos all over here all
over my house
and i don't think that's the best
strategy because he's not thinking about
the four dimensional
thinking surface question deeper
questions potential threats
deeper threads there's got to be an
element of paranoia with the strategies
some people that are strategists that
are not good at strategic thinking
they just do the work and execute they
lack paranoia the higher you go up and
you're an executive leading bigger
armies
you know general mattis is one of the
guys we just booked to speak at one of
our leadership meetings
one of the reasons why bringing them
bringing general mattis is because our
1.200 000 soldiers reported to this guy
he was a leader of 200 000 soldiers and
marines and he's been to war many times
there's a great
you know serious on hbo you can watch it
tells you the story of matters right the
mad dog
mattis is an element of paranoia
there's an element of what if the enemy
does this we do this there's an
element of that and sometimes
strategists don't have that and last but
not least
if you combine your philosophies that
are true proven philosophies that you
hopefully eventually have took me 15
years i just want you to know this
it took me 15 years to get clear in my
method of leadership philosophy
challenging communication
what audience took me a long time to get
there but say you get crystal clear with
your philosophies
you can't compromise the big values and
principles of your philosophies
now you value money in an organization
to help you have more leverage meaning
the bigger you get sometimes people
don't have that money because they use
it more freely they're like ah it
doesn't matter just spend the money
spend the money
the thicker you get with money now
there's more opportunities for you to
capitalize this form of a strategy
because
if you don't have any money and great
opportunities come up so what
if you have great strategies one of the
mistakes you made is you don't have the
cash to buy the other company that's on
sale right
and last but not least if you have the
right differentiation
against your competitors potentially as
a product
as an approach as a target audience as a
way of getting your client
you combine those three togetherness
true to your real vision
now you're eventually going to find
yourself competing with the big dogs of
your industry when you get to that point
let me tell you
it's exciting it's cool but it's almost
like
your entire dream was about one day
fighting for the heavyweight
championship and going into the big rink
and you walk up to mgm grand arena and
it still hasn't hit you
did you see your picture going up
against the heavyweight champion still
hasn't hit you
then you're in there training with the
mirror still hasn't hit you then you
watch the monitor they're about to
introduce you still hasn't hit you
then the music comes on you play
whatever song you want to play and you
go up with your trainers behind you
and you're going whistle
still hasn't hit you then you get into
the ring and then the champion shows up
and he walks in with confidence and he
looks at you
and you never had a championship fight
before
and then you face him and he said it
just got real hopefully by that time
based on how you've strategized you're
ready to knock him out and beat a new
champion
or else if you're not prepared he will
knock you
out gladly so having said that this is
why you ought to spend a little bit more
time
thinking about strategies that's one of
the reasons why i wrote the book your
next five moves that comes out august
18th
by the time you watch it's probably
going to be out already anyways if you
haven't purchased your next five moves
we'll put the link below
for you to go order the next but the
whole thing is mastering the art of
business strategy and i go into the
stuff except deeper for 300 pages
if you want today's topic that i talked
about in pdf
text us the word strategy to three one
zero three four zero one one three two
strategy text strategy to three one zero
three four zero one one three two
again three one zero three four zero one
one three two text award strategy
send you a pdf of today's video and if
you want any other articles about this
topic i'll put it below a couple of them
for you to read
last but not least if you want to watch
a video that has to do with a grand
master strategist thinker like how they
think in the world of business
i gave a talk on this last year in long
beach if you haven't watched it go watch
us thank you so much for watching
everybody take care bye